eu environment ministers meeting on  december 17 in brussels  are expected to agree on new rules to  improve the monitoring and verification  of co2 emissions from ships it will be a  first step towards reducing greenhouse  gas emissions  from international maritime shipping  ministers are also expected to agree on  new rules to reduce the use of plastic  bags  which can persist in the environment for  hundreds of years before they are fully  degraded  they will also see conversions on a new  regulation to reduce pollution from  medium-sized combustion installations  such as energy plants for street blocks  and small industry installations  to better protect human health finally  ministers will also examine the doha  amendment ratification package  proposed by the commission last year  this amendment reflects the eu's  commitment to achieve a 20  reduction of greenhouse gas emissions  over the second period compared to the  level in 1990